here in this video we are going to
showcase to you all the 20 of the
largest creatures of the movie avatar
the ones found on the planet pandora the
fictional pandora biosphere from the
james cameron's avatar movie teams with
a biodiversity of bioluminescent species
ranging from hexapodal animals to other
types of exotic flora and fauna the
pandora ecology forms a vast neural
network spanning the entire lunar
surface into which the navi and other
creatures can connect into there are
very small animals as well as gigantic
ones so here we are only going to
showcase 20 of the biggest found in the
movie and its games so let's get down to
business
number 20 tapirus this is a docile
herbivorous taper like creature that
lives on pandora on a planet with
perfect predators the tabirus fills the
unfortunate role of being the perfect
prey the tapirus is of short stature
with flat elephant-like feet its body is
of light brown color with faint striping
patterns across its sides it is maybe 1
meters tall or 3.3 feet
number 19 the pro lemuris this is a
chattering non-aggressive tree dweller
that prefers the relative safety of the
canopy to the dangers of the rainforest
floor the prolamerus is similar to the
monkeys and apes of earth these polymers
can reach up to one meter in height and
they have large eyes with binocular
vision and an ape-like skull with a
short snout small nostrils and a very
small jaw
number 18 the viper wolf this is a small
hyena slash wolf like carnivore that has
six legs a lean powerful torso and has
evolved to travel swiftly over long
distances in such a prey viper wolves
almost always move in facts that can
mask together into a highly cooperative
hunting party within seconds of finding
prey these wolves of pandora are one
meter tall or as tall as a lion
number 17 the sting bat this stingbad is
a small aerial predator with a highly
developed navigational system and has
four eyes the stingbad has translucent
fangs and claws with predominant
bioluminescence on the wing membrane and
a torso one of the sting balls features
is a scorpion like tail stinger it has a
wingspan of 1.2 meters or 4 feet and
also often equal length
number 16 the turtle peat the turtle
peat is a pandoran creature that looks
like a cross between a turtle and a
starfish
with its large dorsal fin and long tail
the turtle peat is agile underwater when
the sea dwelling therapy emerges from
the water mesmerizing colors start to
shimmer in the translucent area on its
shell this creature is 3.1 meters or 10
feet long and just 1.4 meters tall or
around 4 feet
number 15 the tetrapteron this flying
creature is a class of flamingo-like
bursts that look almost earth-like until
one notices that it has four wings with
two on either side the tetrapteron also
features a unique twin tail used for
balancing its body weight as it hunts
all lands
they hunt in flocks and their main diet
as pandora and fish they have a wingspan
of 1.5 meters or 5 feet across
number 14 the hexapete hexapetes are
some of the most beautiful and fragile
creatures of bandora although a prime
target for any land or aerial predator
the rapid pace of their breeding keeps
them from extinction the hexapede is a
food source for the navi and is one of
the prime targets for navi hunters they
stand 2 meters or 6.5 feet tall and are
also considered the deers of pandora
number 13 the slinger this is one of the
most dangerous creatures on pandora
growing in size up to 2.4 meters or 8
feet in height this land predator slash
carnivore prefers a dense rainforest
habitat and its main food source is the
hexapete when hunting this creature
moves slowly and suddenly through the
forest ferns when it sends a spray its
muscular neck [ __ ] back into a striking
position then snaps forward like a
scorpion
number 12 the thanator xenobiologists
currently believe that this may be the
apex land predator on pandora
reminiscent of a terran lion or most
similar in appearance to that of a
gorgon opposite from the past
this enormous powerful animal is unique
in its ability to lord over its
territory and strike fear into the
largest and fiercest of pandora's
terrestrial carnivores it is more than
eight feet tall or 2.5 meters in height
number 11 the ostropeet with its flat
broad beak and long neck and tail this
gentle animal the ostropede is a
relatively small bird by pandora
standards the ostropedes are impulsive
fidgety creatures whose emotions spread
quickly from one individual to the other
in the form of mimicry therefore they
cause a flying stamp beat of sorts these
animals are 2.78 meters or 9 feet tall
number 10 the navi these are a race of
sentient extraterrestrial humanoids who
inhabit the lush jungle moon of pandora
the indigenous navi are on average
approximately 3 meters or 10 feet tall
with smooth blue colored skin large
yellow eyes and long sweeping tails
their bodies are more slender than
humans they are the only known
extraterrestrial species discovered to
be sapient other than humans
number nine the dire horse these are
nectary wars vaguely horse like an
appearance with very long necks and
small heads
they are roughly the size of an elephant
around 4 meters tall or 13 feet these
animals move together in a loose herd
through the forest feeding on tree
blocks and shrubs
they are used by the navi as mounds just
as humans use horses
number eight the stone bees it is a
large buffalo like herbivore that serves
as one of the main sources of animal
products for the navi as such sturmbies
are primary organizing force in this
clan cultures of the navi people and
they are hurt animals they are extremely
social and highly protective of their
young they are also highly territorial
and will mask for attacks against any
would-be predator they are around 4.5
meters or 15 feet tall
number seven the elu the elu is a large
place your soul-like creature that is
the dye horse of the pandoran ocean
glands with multiple fins flippers and a
long streamlined shape this aquatic back
animal serves the wreath clans like how
the dire horses serve the navy clans of
the forest jungles and plains slick and
slim this aquatic reptilian specimen
with long neck six flippers and rather
like tail is around 7 meters or 23 feet
long
number 6 the mountain banshee
they are large dragon like aerial
predators that are native to pandora
they are used by the navi for hunting
from the air and traveling large
distances unlike most other creatures in
bandura they have only four limbs all of
which are modified into wings these
creatures have a wingspan of around 14
meters or 46 wide and are roughly 10
meters long
number five the stigo beast this is an
unnamed creature of pandora and so we
took it on to ourselves to give it a
name let's call it a stigo beast since
it resembles the stegosaurus of the
jurassic age with its blades and fleshy
spines on its back
they are herbivorous and are very large
around 8-9 meters tall or maybe even
more than 10 meters tall when taking the
plates into consideration they have six
legs and are hurt animals
at number 4 we have the hammerhead
titanother this creature is
approximately 11 meters long and 6.5
meters are 21 feet tall almost twice the
size of an elephant and is essentially a
six-legged monstrous version of earth's
ancient extinct rhinos this massive
grazing creature travels in moderately
large herds of packs of up to 10 to 20
animals and its stampede is let's just
say it can destroy armies
number three the medusa this creature is
a gigantic flying specimen of pandora
its bell is up to 15 meters or 45 feet
in diameter and its tentacles can reach
up to more than 35 meters or more than
110 feet across drifting over the
mountainous tops of pandora these deadly
and beautiful creatures look like alien
versions of a jellyfish or a pandoran
portuguese man of war
number two the great leonopteryx this is
a species of airborne predatory animal
native to pandora also known as the toro
makto scientifically it is known as the
leonoptryx or the winged king lion the
leonoptryx is closely related to the
banshee but it's primarily colored in
red and yellow the wingspan of the
leonopteryx is more than 25 meters or
around 75 to 80 feet across and it can
even exceed 30 meters in some cases it
is the apex predator of bandora
and number one derna lutzer the nilitza
is a sixth guild behemoth that lives in
the coastal waters of the bandora oceans
and can be seen leaping out of the near
shore waters reaching up to 40 meters in
length it is a hyper carnivorous species
and is more of a gigantic version of
earth's dunkleosteus or predatory sharks
it is a massive and armored aquatic
animal with salt-like teeth
and so with that we come to the end of
this video of the 20 largest animals and
creatures of pandora of the movie avatar
be sure to hit that like button for
support and also subscribe if you
haven't to be a part of our minecube
family our mastermind q family anyway
also do click that bell button for
regular updates on new monster videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam
you